if you're broke and you don't want to be
anymore I'm going to reach you some
stats I'm going to blow your mind and
then I'm going to give you six steps so
you don't have to be anymore the average
American has a literal negative net
worth means that babies are richer than
people who are not babies because babies
haven't gone into debt number two the
average US minimum wage employee will
make over a million dollars in their
entire lifetime in earnings and if you
were the median of US income you would
earn $3 million over the course of your
life so the reason staying poor is the
decision is because you know as long as
you continue to work you are going to
make 1 million millions of dollars and
most of the time it's going in places
that don't make sense so challenge
number one is the buy nothing challenge
it's very simple you just buy nothing so
disconnect your credit card from Amazon
leave your wallet at home when you go to
work have no way to pay for stuff if
your gas if your insurance rent car
payment if buy food at discount grocery
stores you pack your lunch that's all if
you buy nothing it is as austere or hard
core as my recommendations may appear I
do not ask people to do things that I
haven't done and so like when I was
taking $2,000 a month me personally I
was in a house with six roommates and I
split my bedroom with one roommate and
so like yeah two beds two dudes looking
at each other like every night when I
was making a million dollars a month I
was living on less than 15 and so the
key takeaway that shifted how I thought
about making money and more importantly
keeping money is that well wealth is
actually a ratio between what you earn
and what you need and the number one
rule of money is spend less than you
make and so I always like being super
super conservative with my expenses
relative to what I make because I don't
like spending money that I feel like I
do those of you who the the three
YouTube uh odd commenters uh who think
that this is a prop set you get just
look out the
window it's all AI the first thing you
have to do to become wealthy is that you
have to decide to become wealthy and you
have to decide that it's under your
control you have to switch from victim
to Victor so as much as you may have had
a disadvantage or maybe you found a Deb
or you made poor decision you have to be
the person who's most powerful in your
life around money now the third thing
and this is the one that really kills me
is that in the US 35% of every paycheck
goes towards paying one thing you know
it is Banks lenders for debt 35%
that's because people don't think about
their mortgage as debt they don't think
about their car payment as debt they
don't think about their credit cards as
debt there's a reason that banks are 100
plus years old because they don't go out
of business they make so much money on
money money is their product and you
keep buying their money from them at a
bad price man at a compounding price
that goes up every single year and those
people don't do the math on compounding
but like right now so many people are
trying to get 10% 9% returns in stock
market with their credit cards 24%
against them and so the easiest thing
you can do right at the beginning will
pay off the things that are guaranteed
24% negative returns they're guaranteed
it's amazing they're guaranteed returns
against you being wealthy compound
interest is the Eighth Wonder in Charlie
M and you want to face off head-to-head
against the Eighth Wonder World against
your
gos bad idea so the thing is that if
you're earning enough money and then you
have the right habits being broke is a
temporary status so step one save for an
emergency fund and so these steps are
similar to D Ram's baby steps because I
think he's permanent 100 times over and
it's worth modeling success so number
one sa for your work fund which is
basically between $1,000 and $55,000 so
reason that so many people don't hit
their savings goals is because something
happens right and so it's like have a
wor for when your AC breaks or when your
carburetor needs to be replaced the
thing is is that things that are
unexpected you can expect them to happen
you just don't know which one it's going
to be because if you look at a year it's
like about once a month they'll have
something unexpected her and you know
it's going to cost you and so it's just
preparing for the expense not which
expense it is but what about like dead
should i p it on first no learn to save
money first and just watch the amount go
up get to that L but I say this because
I'm not trying to make your life
difficult they trying to tell you what I
did to get here and for those of you who
find that useful you can model whatever
you want that habit has stuck with me so
even when I was making a million dollars
a month early Ro in my career our rent
was 1,200 bucks a month so then we ball
out and get appetizers and we get the
Bang Bang Shrimp at bone bone so you
know sh out to V I took like $100 felt
like a like a rich guy so I say this cuz
some people just immediately change how
they live when they make more money even
the fact I was able to start in 23 was
because I saved every dollar I made so I
could have 50,000 something it wasn't
like I was I was making crazy money I
think I I think I made 55,000 or 60,000
I think my first year out of college and
then I made I want to
say 70 or 80 something like that the
next year and I save 50 after taxes so
I'm going to show you something really
quick if you have a $200 pair of Jordans
that you really want to buy now you
might want to buy them today and let's
say you're 25 years old you're like I I
deserve these I work really hard for
them okay fine but that
$200 invested just in the S&P 500 we're
not even getting to s& 500 I'll talk
about that later between now and the
time you retire do you want to know what
that actually is yeah $200 per
shoes and we're going to give it 40
years we're going to make our return
9% additional cation zero instead of
buying that $200 pair of shoes when you
were 65 it could be over $6,000 if you
just invested in the S&P so if you
wouldn't buy those shoes for
$6,000 then maybe don't buy them today
for $200 when you buy Jordans it's not
there's no upside that money is gone
it's just $6,000 that could have been
something that's just going to be zero
and that's a big loss when you do it
over and over and over again right like
6,000 $7,000 does take a lot of those to
add up to a million 130 of those
purchases is a million you probably do
that in a couple years and so that's
personal risk now business risk if you
take good business risk there's upside
the thing is is that sometimes you can't
take this business risk because your
personal risk is too high and so for me
my whole life I've tried to jam this
risk as low as I possible good so that I
can go on the offensive on the business
side I saved as much as I could when I
had my job so start a gy that was a big
Ritz but I had I lived almost nothing in
Baltimore so that I could take that
swing and if I hadn't had the basics
there I would not have been able to take
that shot and I sold those businesses
that lost everything two more times if I
had had to go into debt just to live
then I would have never been able to
take their second and third shots and so
the whole point is is like you will
increase your shots on gooll by living
risk-free or low risk in your personal
life you'll be able to fail more like I
failed more times than it I'm telling
you I had nine failed businesses I seven
failed Partnerships like I have many
failures but the only reason I can get
back up is because I don't have this big
thing that I have to take care of it's
like I know that I can live on peanut
butter sandwiches and and egg whites
mixing uh protein protein powder from
the gas station with water I I can do
that I because I have I've already done
and I flipped
them right now like I've had these
like I like them they're fine they're
perable so I live with almost nothing
and it doesn't bother me cuz I know how
I was pretty content when I was Bor I'm
pretty content now right I like the game
more now so I'm bringing all these
points up because saving money won't
make you money but it will allow you to
think further out and make bigger bets
which absolutely will make you more
money if I had not done that I wouldn't
have a gym if I hadn't been the gym I
wouldn't have done the gym turnour if I
done the gym turn around I wouldn't have
done gym launch didn't do gym launch I
would have been able to do Prestige Labs
Prestige Labs I would able to sell do
Allen from there wouldn't be able to do
acis.com so like it sounds small but
it's a tiny Domino that you could
control all right step two which is you
can begin paying off debt there's two
ways of thinking about paying off debt
there's The Logical way and the
psychological way I would recommend the
psychological way so let's say that
you've got three different uh you know
cards than you owe you've got one that's
20% one that's 15% almost 10% okay logic
would state that you should go after the
20% but psychology would state that you
should go after the one that you can pay
off fastest
so my recommendation despite the fact
that the math would say oh I should pay
off the the bigger the one that cost you
the most first you're going to pay them
all off eventually and you've been
dealing with all three of them for like
years now so chill maybe just follow the
process which is get a win faster that's
the whole pointy and so pay them off in
reverse order of speed and paying them
off so it's like boom I knock going out
might knock went out like you want to
have those little like jackpots but
organize them so you have more of them
sooner in your process now if the one
that you have the highest in on is also
the fastest off that definitely that's a
double wi like you can have like three
quick wins and you're just waiting like
n months to do that because you have to
pay this big net off it's like just get
the win and to be clear when I'm talking
about paying off debt I'm talking
primarily on Consumer Debt and credit
cards and things like that the de that
we're not going to deal with it is going
to be like House St like you're more
dtic if you have a car I would recommend
getting rid of that uh and trading it
down easiest way to pay off your car is
pay off a chaper car and trade in the
one that you have just just you're
you're living beyond your means it's
just that you thought your means were
higher than they are but that's okay
that's why you're watching this I would
give you one mental image that should
hopefully drag through why this is so
important so you got to save about 10
bucks a day for you to get a million
dollars in 40 years so the ma is $250 a
month that you would put away and the
compounds at 9% then you can be a
million in 40 years that feels so so
easy to do the only thing easier is not
doing and if you were to just put $500 a
month away at $500 a month you'd be at
2.1 million in 40 years now to be clear
most people can live on about 4ish per
and that's with never touching the
principle at some point you can start
unwinding it and spending the money
right but at 4% which is very safe
amount that you can that you can spend
off that you can live 80 grand a year
this is the gameification that I would
want you to think about which is that
for every $250 that you save every month
it's a million doll in just basically
just use that as your map and you're
like wait so if I save 1,000 they're
like right that's 4 million you're like
if I save 2,000 like that's 8 million
right and so the thing is is that's
where you're going to get into this game
we're going to be like Fiji Water you're
like screw Fiji Water right like I I'll
use the spigot in the back now if you're
watching this you're like well then
didn't you spend all this money on this
yeah there's levels right but we got to
get from level one first which is we got
to spend less than we make we got to we
got to save what we're keeping okay step
three is you're actually going to kind
of like double down on step one which is
this is that you expand your emergency
savings $1 to $5,000 is not real
emergency savings that's like just to
prove to yourself that you've learn how
to save money the real emergency savings
is really having like 3 to 6 months of
living expenses saved up so you can just
like leave it in an interest uh bearing
account which there's plenty of places
that'll give you 5 or 6% at least today
I'm making you this video on the money
you put in there the magic of of this is
that when you put that cash there your
level of anxiety around everything else
in life will go down
and this will then snowball in being
able to actually take your eyes from
paycheck to paycheck and look up then
this is where saving money makes you
money is that it allows you to see the
opportunities around you because you
actually can go on the offense now be
clear we're not going to invest this
money this money is just your brick of
safety that you always have because you
don't know what's going to happen next
so that seems the way to step forward
which is eliminate risky spending so if
you have a car lease turn it in all
right and then buy a $5,000 cler all
right so 5 Grand 10 grand in cash again
we're we're at step four now all right
so you've already you've already saved
some money you've learned how to save
you paid off some debt now trade that
thing in had own every car we had in
cash and all we had bought and used I
think my first few cars all had uh over
100,000 W that was just how I thought
everyone bought
cars negotiate look for a car that's
100,000 years old look at Carfax to have
something that has low insurance and low
uh repairs and a lot of that stuff you
can look at average cost for repair by
different Vehicles next thing is if you
have multiple cars downgrade to one I
mean l I've lived with one car for years
I just have a great story about I
haven't told the story forever so the
first time I drove up to a gym launch
event so we had I think like 30 or 40 by
of the time we had an event for all the
gym owners to come out to this was an
Alber C New Mexico that's where Le and I
CH at the time and as I pulled up I
pulled up at lela's car now his was how
C there was no other car and it had a
crack in the windshield and a dead in
the door see me and one of the ladies
who's in the group was like H I thought
you were supposed to be rich I was like
oh you should see my backing here I know
what game I'm playing the game you're
judging me on is a stupid game you know
if you have kids maybe there's
considerations there but even then like
is there a way that you can just use
foresight and say how will we share one
car because there are many families that
do have kids and just share one car and
so if they can do it so can do and what
you're doing is you're paying for
convenience but that convenience is
costing remember $500 a month what's
that that's $2 million that's for that
convenience is it is it is it $2 million
worth it probably not and so what I want
to push on is like what's your what's
your Vice some people like they love
going down to e people love shoes that's
guys anrs right uh some people love
clothes some people love vacation so
some people just like live in a
neighborh that shouldn't be it you've
got to look at how that translates into
time it translates into future money so
there's the two big measuring sticks I
want you to use is if you can translate
all the stuff you have so like that car
is a $600 a month lease that you have
right that means that let's say that you
make $100 a day right say 12250 hour
okay let's say and that's let's say
that's post tax so you're at 15 or
something like that
okay that means that if you work 4 weeks
a month 22 days of work days in a month
you're working six of your 22 days for
the car that you drive to work
with Okay like people aren't translating
the money into the time and let's say
that you spend you know $1,200 a month
on on your lease and maybe you know
wherever you live right okay well now
you got 12 days so we got 6 and 12 we're
at 18 of our 22 days you sh you don't
have W left right it's like how much of
each of these days am I am I using up to
just do my fixed cost
and these are the ones that you can
completely Jam down only thing that
people hate is your ego and when I said
earlier that I'm not going to ask you to
do something I haven't done I was a
white color consultant who saved $50,000
and I had a condom and I then got rid of
that and then basically moved into my
far drove across the country didn't have
a place to live uh had a guy like
basically allow me to rent my bedroom
for $400 a month and then I like I my my
gym R which is $5,000 but I was like
Jesus I'm not I'm not try get anymore r
on so I lived in my gym I I lived on
zero I was hopeless I lived inside my
gym like it was fine it was just not
legal I had a client say like oh my God
you should be taking better care of this
car it was like dirty and I had like
washed it or whatever that tiny action
was representative of hundreds and
thousands of smaller actions I hope you
get to where I'm at right now and so I'm
very grateful for that man at that time
who was going to take that
sacrifice for me to do what what I can
do now so a great question that I have
for you is what are you willing to give
up to be a
milia rather than what are you willing
to do because a lot of times in the
beginning it's about it's about
elimination not addition the people that
you're going to get out of your life
it's the expenses that you're going to
get out of your life it's the postur
it's going to be the the showing off if
you aren't willing to sacrifice anything
to become a millionaire you never will
become uh the dormant of my building
started fall some steps and he went from
having a $600 month lease to buying a
car in cash that he now own that's a big
downgrade for what he had but he's
paying off his debt and now he's like
just seeing every month my debt go down
he's like it's so like reinforcing I was
like in my company when I found out that
some of the highest earners were living
paycheck to paycheck I like talk to more
of them about this I really wanted to
figure out what it was and so what was
interesting about it was that the people
who were the wealthiest the ones who had
the most saved up the most invested were
not offering the highest
earners again it's this this
misconception that people think make a
lot of money have a lot of money and
often times that's not the case at all
and I don't know about you I would
rather be underestimated for how much
money I got and so the real question is
do you want to look rich or do you want
to be rich and I think a lot of you guys
if you're being honest with yourselves
want to look rich you want people to
give your dabs on being rich you don't
actually want to have the security me
I'm actually very risky person I hate I
hate the feeling of needing money I hate
the feeling of needing money more than
you
do that's why I did everything in my
life so that I wouldn't have to feel
that way real F your tolerance for
poverty is higher you've accustomed to
that feeling you're willing to deal with
that
stress I'm be clear you got a family
things like that yeah it's just a spouse
conversation is the neighbor we need to
be we farle like you have to be real
about this and you're not going to keep
up with the Jones today but you will
pass the Jones eventually if you want to
look rich long term the best way to do
that is to actually be rich because you
will be stressfree or less stressed
about money and I think that does have
material change and how your life feels
so I'll just read you a quote from
Charlie W he said the first 100 Grand is
a but you got to do it I don't
care what you have to do if it means
walking everywhere not eating anything
that wasn't purchased like a coupon find
a way to get your hands on a underr
after today e off the gas a little bit
you mind you he said this years ago so
it's probably close to150 maybe $200,000
today and so I say this because you want
to make it fun and so I gave you my
little story about the doorm earlier put
it on an excelion if I save this much
every month if I save this much every
month and see how quickly you can knock
it down right so the next one is uh is
around mortgages if you're renting you
want to downgrade to something that's
cheaper as cheap as you possibly can if
you have a mortgage that you can afford
uh harder to get out of that and so you
can refinance if they're if the rates
are lower if they're not lower then you
want to try and get a 15-year fixed and
that way you can just try and pay it
down as fast as possible the idea is
that you just want to pay the house off
and now we don't have to worry about it
unless the government comes after for
problem with taxes well I can tell you
that living in a cash B for house uh is
very chill but you're learing okay my
car is paid forign cash my house is paid
forign cash what happens is that your
earning capacity start snowballing
because if you don't have this car
payment and you don't have a mortgage
all of a sudden you're like whoa I'm
only working 2 days a month for my
normal expenses in the other 20 I have
now for going all in on investments in
either myself or assets that about
overti so step five is invest
15% of pre-tax income pre-tax income
into stuff that's going to go up over
time now the way that I like to think
about this is automate Investments
frictional lie spending so basically you
make it hard to spend easy to save easy
to invest and so I like to take the
things that have to get have to get
saved have to get invested off the top
before I begin everything else right now
I still would have another bucket there
that would be education that I would
invest in if you're like man let's talk
about the S&P 500 I don't know if I have
the the money for that right and to be
to do educational stuff it's like well
spend less and if like I can't spend
less you can always spend less right um
but you can still split it and say okay
I'll put 15% pre tax into investing I'll
put another 15% pre- tax into my
education cuz that going to increase
your capacity cuz listen as soon as you
can replace what it cost you in
education for that investment everything
else is gravy it's like house money and
so like the whole goal of the first
educational investment is to cover
itself once that happens like it's all
doubling down after that and that's my
recommendation is like the day that you
stop investing with in your education
getting more skills is that that you
decide that you don't want to make any
more money than you probably are by the
way this isn't investment advice you can
do whatever the hell you want this is
just be telling you what I told my team
so next one is a little money habit
still underneath step five is you want
to check your accounts daily so this is
something that I recommend for everybody
who's basically before your savings
schol um I stop looking at my accounts
every day once we cross like 20 million
that was when I literally stopped
checking every day cuz the volatility
sto making sense it make sense anymore
but you want want to have a pulse for
your money and so you want to know you
want to you want to know what's coming
in what's going out like you want to you
want to feel that and when you're
looking at expension like that's a lot
for me cuz you know how much that hits
your account and like that that was a
good inflow you're willing to to to to
spend more in some areas that you're
like I'm getting returns there but like
you can't know that unless you be
account every day you have that flow so
if you want to know something wild so if
you were 20 years old right now and you
do the thing that I'm about to tell you
it's going to sound insane but you would
have $50 million saved up at the end so
here's how it
works you take on an extra job you work
an extra shift you make an extra $2,500
a month that means you drive Uber you
you say you go to your boss and say I
have more time can I do someone else's
job or can I look at other jobs and take
portions of that for more pay and a lot
of times if you just offer to work more
businesses will pay you more because
they have more work to do and so you can
make an extra ,000 $2,000 $3,000 a month
but if you made an extra $2,500 a month
and you put that every single month
towards just investing into the S&P 5
again not s just S&P all the other stuff
we said stays we're just doing this on
top and we're not touching it so then
you would
have 55 years of compounding at
99.7% and let's say you're starting
amount with
zero and you're going to put $2,500 a
month away you did that for 55 years
you'd have $52 million at the
end like you'd be ultra high net
worth and so I I say this because wealth
is a decision it's something that you
can control and it starts with spending
less than what you make it's about
increasing your earning capacity
segmenting and paying off the things
that are that are that are dumb to be
paying for locking in the negative
compounding against you and blocking
those so that you you can start the
positive compounding developing the
simple habit of saving something then
paying off smaller ones then saving up
bigger ones then getting a little bit
more on the offensive restructuring
house debt so that you can pay it off
faster once you're there then start
snowballing then you go more
aggressively into you work the extra
shifts you invest the 15 pre-tax maybe
invest another 15 pre-tax into yourself
if I to pick between the two Bar None
not even close I'd invest in me because
your ability to earn more using money is
going to always be higher than the S&P
500 even know so let's say that you put
$10,000 into the S&P 500 and it grows
10% you have 1,000 bucks great let's say
instead you take the $10,000 and I said
that working that extra shift well maybe
instead of uh uh shoveling snow you buy
a snowblower and now the snowblower
takes you from doing three driveways a
day to doing 20 when you knock doors and
say Hey you know snow blow your your
driveway for you with 7ex your earning
capacity will that make you more than an
extra ,000 this year yes buy a lot buy a
long shot and so the key is not thinking
about uh what you can do passively with
the money although I I like having this
understanding of it especially in the
beginning it's about increasing your
active income so here's the craziest
thing that $52 million that you would
have that's being made by someone no
matter
what think about this for a second if
you didn't change your habits you'd more
or less make the same amount of money
but that 35% % of the American paycheck
is going to someone and not someone is
taking that money and putting into
something that Couts and they're doing
it for the entirety of your life and so
the question just comes down to who do
you want that $50 million to belong to
do you want it to belong to the banks
and their shareholders or do you want it
to belong to you but either way that
money is being made it's just whether
it's going to be you who pass it at the
end so the last step just to be clear is
that you pay off your mortgage then all
of your basic living expenses are are
covered your fixed costs are done and
now all of that unlocks even more
investment into your long-term Legacy
now this works really well when paired
with the the uh the 30 by2 all right so
30X 12 working challenge is basically
you work 30 days straight no weekends 12
hours a day and you don't take days off
now what happens is now everyone like
that's not sustainable that's why I said
30 days not the rest of your life the
point is is that you'll realize at the
end of days that you can work harder
than you thought you could you can go a
week or two without taking a day off and
you're not going to die cuz Believe It
or Not thousands of years we didn't have
weekends weekends are A New Concept
that's happened as soon as factories
were invented and I think it was a way
to get even more something out of people
I can't even remember what it was the
point is is that if you stop spending
all your money and then you take all the
time when you normally would spend money
and then make money you get a double you
reduce the negative and add to the
positive and see how much damage you can
can do in 30 days and then then you
could say is it worth it for me to get
what I want